Barack Obama
accurately called out the toxic left at
a very interesting event called the
Obama Foundation Summit yesterday Obama
you remember that guy I have to tell you
I think what Barack Obama says here is
pretty damn accurate I have made clear
the toxic left is a small part of the
left but it exists and it's really
destructive and counterproductive Barack
Obama in this clip we're going to look
at hard to imagine a more accurate
assessment of this sliver of the left
let's take a listen you know this this
idea of Purity and you're never
compromised and you're always
politically woke and all that stuff you
should get over that quickly the world
the world is messy
their ambiguities
people who
do really good stuff
have flaws
people who you are fighting
may love their kids
and
you know
share certain things with you and and I
think that one danger I see among young
people particularly on College camps is
Malia and I talk about this Yara goes to
school with my daughter
um
but I do get a sense sometimes now among
certain young people and this is
accelerated by social media there is
this sense sometimes of the way of me
making change is to be as judgmental as
possible about other people
folks this is verbatim the stuff I've
been saying for four years on the show
these are genuinely wise words I've been
careful to say there is a small but very
loud part of the left
the right is almost completely Bonkers
nuts okay that's clear that's a clear
part of the show
but there is this slice of the left
that's very loud
and they will allow the perfect to
become the enemy of the good
they will use Purity tests they will
dismiss entire groups of people over uh
uh the narcissism of what we sometimes
call small differences and in my
universe in the left media platform they
often try to ruin what people like me
and others are doing because we're not
perfect by their standard
and this is part of why the left loses
slash doesn't win as much as we could
let's continue and that's enough like if
I tweet or hashtag about how you didn't
do something right or use the word wrong
verb or then I can sit back and feel
pretty good about myself because man you
see how awoke I was I called you out
I'm gonna get on TV
watch my show
watch grown-ish
um
you know that's not
that's not activism
that's not bringing about change you
know it
if if all you're doing is casting stones
uh you know you're probably not going to
get that far
that's easy to do
there are lots of people who I know
don't like this and these are the same
people that get mad at me sometimes when
I say hey you know it might be better to
get this win a tangible step forward it
but we we might benefit from that even
if it's not perfect or even if some of
the people helping us get this win don't
agree with us about this other area here
particularly on some of these cultural
issues and the way I understand what the
former president is saying is that there
are shared values and desires that are
much broader than our exact political
orientation you might ask me about my
position on 50 different issues and you
and I might only agree on 30 but there
are some overriding values that we share
particularly that the right doesn't and
there's going to be ambiguity there are
contradictions we all you know as as
much as we all like to be consistent you
know when I say to you Hey listen
um
if I don't praise or blame a republican
for gas prices then I have to try to be
consistent and apply the same standard
to a Democratic president we're all
trying to be consistent but there are
contradictions and there are ambiguities
and some of them come from all sorts of
different things in our background or
our upbringing or education or whatever
the case may be the Nuance is great but
we can't allow those differences to get
in the way of the progress that is
available for all of us to take and this
includes things like to be perfectly
Frank
the idea of if it's not Bernie then I
don't care if it's Hillary or Trump it's
sort of all the same wow were those
people proven wrong and again it's a
small slice of the left but I love this
I think Barack Obama is absolutely spot
on here
when you're working during the day when
you're on the go and you're in the mood
for something sweet don't reach for the
candy bar go for something that's just
as good but without the sugar and carbs
our sponsor monk pack makes delicious
keto granola bars and nut and Seed bars
they're tasty crunchy gooey sweet and
salty I love them but each bar has only
one gram of sugar two to three net carbs
and about 150 calories perfect if you're
doing keto or low carb or low sugar you
can have a treat that feels indulgent
and satisfying without the guilt monk
pack comes in flavors like sea salt dark
chocolate caramel sea salt they just
launched two new flavors I love peanut
butter cocoa chip and dark chocolate
cocoa my favorite thing is the texture
I've tried a lot of these nut bars
granola bars monk pack is superior if
you don't agree you get your money back
and it is the perfect holiday gift go to
monkpak.com and get 20 off your first
order with the code Pacman the link is
down below